ينضم الينا من اونتاريو في كندا الدكتور
مايكل لينك استاذ القانون الدولي ومقرر
الامم المتحده السابق لحقوق الانسان في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه مرحبا بك دكتور مايكل
لينك كيف وجدت الرد الاسرائيلي اليوم
والدفاع الاسرائيلي في محكمه العدل
الدوليه بالمقارنه مع الدفوع التي قدمها
فريق جنوب افريقيا بالامس والادله
والبراهين التي وضعها امام
القضاه
في
الامس جنوب افريقيا
اعتمدت طريقه الهجوم حيث قامت بتقديم عدد
كبير من الوقائع لتثبت انها اباده جماعيه
وكان هناك ايضا عوده الى تصريحات
اسرائيليه من مسؤولين اسرائيليين تثبط نيه
الاباده الجماعيه اما مهمه اسرائيل اليوم
فكانت محاوله الدفاع
عن نفسها وقامت
بهجوم من طرفها قال انما او قالت ان ما
ارتكب في السابع من اكتوبر كان فظيعا وانه
اباده جماعيه واننا نحن الشعب الذي تعرض
لاباده جماعيه وليس
فلسطينيين اعتمدت حججا تقنيه وقالت ليس
هناك اي خلاف او نزاع بين جنوب افريقيا
واسرائيل وبالتالي صلاحيه للمحكمه هذه حجه
سوف لن تكون مقنعه براي كذلك اعتبرت ان
جنوب
افريقيا تنحاز الى جانب حماس
بمجرد اذا رفع هذه القضيه انا لا اعتقد ان
هذا سوف يساعد اسرائيل في اقناع
القضاه سوف يسقطون هذه الحجه واذا كان هذا
افضل ما يمكن ان يردوا به فهذا ليس حجه
قويه نقطه ارتها اسرائيل اليوم هي قضيه
الدفاع عن النفس وهذا ما سوف يكون على
المحكمه ان تتنبه له تقول اسرائيل ما حصل
لنا لقد تعرضنا لاعتداء في الساب من
اكتوبر وجب علينا ان ندافع عن انفسنا
بدخول غزه ما قالته اسرائيل من حيث وقائع
الحرب هو انه اولا نحن لا نسبب الدمار
والموت ب حماس تسبب ذلك بالنسبه الى
المدنيين الذين ماتوا نحن اسفون على ذلك
ولكن هذا ليس خطانا هو خطا حماس ام وهذا
هو التجديد الرئيسي فيما يقولونه دكتور
مايكل واضح دكتور مايكل في موضوع استناد
الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه في الدفاع عن
يعني استناد الفريق القانوني الاسرائيلي
في الدفاع عن اسرائيل امام المحكمه
استناده الى الحجج التقنيه بمعنى القول
انه لا يمكن اثبات ان لدى اسرائيل نيه
مسبقه بارتكاب اباده لاوجود ل منازعه مع
جنوب افريقيا لا ولايه قضائيه للمحكمه في
هذه القضيه هذه الامور
باعتقادك كيف من شانها ان تؤثر على مسار
القضيه برمتها الدعوه
برمتها بعد هذين اليومين يمكن ان نقول ان
جنوب افريقيا قدمت قضيه من حيث مستوى
الدمار عدد الضحايا والاصابات وتدمير
المرافق المدنيه مثل المدارس
والجوامع والمستشفيات وتدمير غزه في
العديد من المواقع اذا قدمت جنوب افريقيا
قضيه مقنعه بالنسبه ايضا الى عدد
التصريحات التي سمعناها من القاده
والمسؤولين الاسرائيليين التي تثبت نيه
بارتكاب الاباده الجماعيه